bonsoir vous l'avez reconnu c'est gold
amir qui hélas emmuré seul face à ces
soldats israéliens qui lui demande des
comptes nous sommes à la fin de la
guerre du kippour et ses soldats sont en
train de me demander pourquoi israël
n'at-il pas attaquer militairement plus
tôt alors aujourd'hui le dossier des
brûlures de l'histoire c'est la guerre
du kippour qui résonne encore beaucoup
dans notre mémoire pourquoi et bien
parce que justement l'idée de la
possibilité d'une paix au proche orient
va sans doute commencer à exister après
cette guerre et puis l'actualité ce soir
ce sera des révélations sur la période
de vichy les français tous collabos tous
résistants évidemment c'est plus
compliqué que cela ils ont acclamé
d'abord pétain quelques mois après le
général de gaulle vous en saurez plus
avec des conversations secrètes sous
l'occupation mais tout de suite le
dossier
depuis la poignée de main de washington
entre rabin et arafat la paix après un
demi-siècle de souffrance et de violence
est en marche au proche orient
lorsque voici quelques mois nous avions
choisi la guerre du kippour comme
premier dossier de ce magazine nous
ignorions naturellement que l'histoire
galoper en coulisses bonsoir l'actualité
nous a rattrapés mais plus que jamais
pour la comprendre il nécessaire de
regarder dans le rétroviseur la guerre
de kippour la quatrième guerre entre
israël et ses voisins arabes marque une
rupture dans l'histoire du proche orient
avec pierre milza historien professeur à
l'institut d'études politiques nous
allons voir les secrets politiques
militaires et diplomatiques de cette
guerre nous verrons aussi et surtout
d'ailleurs si le processus de paix qui a
débouché à washington le 13 septembre
dernier ne s'est pas amorcé il ya vingt
ans après la guerre du kippour nous
allons regarder tout de suite comment
l'opinion internationale et comment la
presse internationale réagit à la guerre
du kippour tout de suite la revue de
presse
le 7 octobre l'orient-le jour sentir une
stricte informations
la pravda le même jour dénonce israël a
attaqué les troupes égyptiennes dans le
secteur du golfe de suez ces nouvelles
agressions ont été préparés et planifiés
à l'avancé par tel aviv
le 8 octobre le figaro parle de guerre
du kippour le terme restera
le times se contentent d'information sur
la situation militaire
dans le monde du 9 octobre le
correspondant du caire câble on n'ose
pas encore parler de victoire quelle que
soit l'issue des combats les arabes ont
remporté une victoire ils auront détruit
l'image complaisamment répandue de
fanfarons tout juste apte à battre en
retraite au premier revers
[Musique]
je vous ai lu sourire aux commentaires
de la pravda oui bah on est obligé de
sourire quand on sait que les
soviétiques étaient parfaitement au
courant de ce qui allait se passer
depuis pas mal de temps ne serait ce que
le fait qu'ils aient retiré les quelques
conseillers militaires qu'ils avaient
réintroduit ennuis puisque c'est qu'ils
sont la vraie mine qui sont partis en 72
non ferreux ouvriers 73 aurait plusieurs
centaines qui reviennent et peu de temps
avant la guerre il rapatrie ses
conseillers militaires dont les
soviétiques sont parfaitement au courant
de ce qui va se passer alors évidemment
on serait un peu c'est très vrai qu'on
revienne sur les buts de la guerre les
buts de sadate et de à ça quand tu es
déclenché cette guerre pourquoi cette
guerre dont une question un peu simple
comment elle peut commencer bon à la
guerre comme en six ans auparavant avec
l'occupation de territoires syriens voir
une cavale alors damien et la
cisjordanie et puis à celle ci n'arrive
pas bon ça c'est israël avant la guerre
des six jours c'est qu'israël avant la
guerre des six jours voilà les
territoires qui sont donc conquis alors
d'été on voit qu israël double son
territoire sans compter sinaï et
quadruples son territoire aux mains
triple son territoire en comptant deux
scénarii d'orgueil occupation par les
israéliens pour garder ses joueurs de
ces trois territoires les plus claires
sont simples apparemment tout ça il
s'agit de les reconquérir - une
différence fondamentale entre les
objectifs des syriens ne parlons pas des
autres pour l'instant jordanie où les
autres pays arabes et ceux de sa date
pour les syriens le problème est simple
s'agit de reconquérir par la force si
c'est possible la partie du gol ans qui
a été perdu en 67 c'est pratiquement
impossible dans six arrivées
militairement ils pensent y arriver mais
clairement il rêve d'y arriver
militairement sadate est infiniment plus
réaliste sadate prépare depuis plusieurs
années la récupération du sinaï est
d'une tout autre manière ce que veut
sada et s'est infligé sur la rive est du
canal des pertes suffisante à
l'adversaire le faire reculer
suffisamment démontré avec ac d'éclat
que les amères apps sont maintenant
capables de faire reculer la remise rien
pour opposition force du moins de
moindres faiblesses pouvoir traiter la
le sinaï et j'y serai je vous interromps
voyons maintenant le film de la guerre
le 6 octobre 1973 les soldats israéliens
en position sur la rive orientale du
canal du suez s'apprête à célébrer le
yom kippour ils ne sont que quatre cent
trente six officiers compris la plupart
des soldats sont en permission pour les
fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]
à 14 heures après un énorme pilonnages
d'artillerie les commandos égyptiens
emmenées par le général fazli chef
d'état major de l'armée franchissent le
canal
grâce à la logistique soviétique 500
blindés traverse à leur tour et en
france la ligne bar lev établi à la fin
de la guerre de six jours
[Musique]
à la même heure exactement au nord sur
le plateau du golan les syriens attaque
avec trois divisions d'infanterie et un
millier de chars en face il ya moins de
200 chars et permissions oblige quelques
centaines d'israéliens ils sont
bousculés
en israël la surprise est totale la
pagaille générale la radio lance les
ordres de mobilisation on évacue le
civil des hôpitaux les voitures et les
autobus sont réquisitionnés en toute
hâte les militaires font du stop pour
gagner le front
en début de soirée le 6 la situation est
dramatique
les forces de tsahal recule partout les
pertes sont lourdes 500 morts des
milliers de blessés
c'est au nord que la position des
israéliens est la plus critique
pénétrant à l'intérieur du golan des
chars syriens épaulés par des
parachutistes sont en vue du lac de
tibériade le coeur d'israël est menacé
c'est l'existence même de l'état hébreu
qu'étrange
comment l'armée d'israël at elle pu se
faire surprendre ainsi
quelques jours plus tôt les frontières
semblait calme et satellite américain
avait bien signalé des mouvements de
troupes dans la zone du canal et sur le
golan et les services de renseignement
avaient confirmé ces informations mais à
jérusalem on ne voit rien d'inquiétant
dans ce déploiement de force il s'agit
des habituels manoeuvre d'odom des
armées égyptiennes et syriennes la cia
de son côté formel le franchissement du
canal représente une menace techniques
hors de portée de l'armée de saddam
secrétaire d'état américain qui suggère
particulièrement bien informé jugent
improbable le déclenchement d'une guerre
par les arabes moshe dyan a refusé une
mobilisation générale qui risque de
jeter la panique dans la population
il décide d'annuler les permissions mais
il est trop tard la majorité des soldats
sont sur les routes ou déjà chez eux
[Musique]
seul david et lazare le chef d'état
major israélien croire à l'imminence
d'une guerre il préconise de rééditer le
coup de 67 d'attaquer le 1er
mai le premier ministre golda meir est
absente le 2 octobre elle est encore à
vienne où elle négocie avec le
chancelier autrichien brüno kreis qui le
passage par l'autriche des juifs d'union
soviétique
dans l'après midi du 5 à la veille du
grand pardon tout s'arrête en israël
c'est à l'aube du 6 à 4 heures du matin
précisément que le chef des services
secrets israéliens prévient moshe dyad
ministre de la défense l'adac conjugués
des égyptiens des syriens aura lieu
avant le coucher du soleil les
américains réveil golda meir en pleine
nuit ils ont la certitude d'une attaque
à rabat 18 heures die hard et golda meir
convoque l'état major pour préparer une
série de raids aériens mais à 6 heures
du matin l'ambassadeur américain met en
garde contre une guerre préventive qui
serait mal accueillie par l'opinion
internationale il faut laisser
l'initiative de la tac aux pays arabes
golda meir cède israël ne bougera pas
en début d'après midi le conseil des
ministres est en réunion quant à
l'officier livide à bord de la nouvelle
ils ont attaqué il est 14 heures les
sirènes hurlent dans tout le pays la
quatrième guerre israélo arabe vient de
commencer arrêtons nous un instant
pierre milza ce 6 octobre on vient de
voir que le gouvernement israélien était
prévenu de l'attak pourquoi ne bouge
t-il pas quelle est la raison de cet
immobilisme bon alors d'abord il
faudrait pas fait rétrospectivement
c'est bien de dhahyane et de golda meir
des colombes c'est à peu près le
contraire miré du jeu rencontrées non
plus naturellement on peut penser que si
elle n'a pas intervenue c'est qu'elle
avait des raisons profondes ces raisons
profondes c'est tout simple ça a été dit
dans le film les américains bon c'est
vrai que on sait vers 4 heures du matin
que les égyptiens et les syriens ont
attaqué on pense que c'est vers 18
heures ça sera bien 14 heures donc on
peut encore faire quelque chose tenter
de rééditer le coup de 1967 pourquoi on
le fait pas parce que très clairement
les américains disent attention et en
est que la situation internationale a
changé que l'image des différents pays
en jambes a changé il est hors de
question pour israël de pouvoir faire
une attaque préventive ou préventives il
faut qu israël soit attaqué soit en
légitime défense pour que les américains
eux-mêmes aux prises avec la situation
internationale difficile la guerre de du
vietnam n'est pas terminé il ya du chili
puisse aider dans un deuxième temps les
israéliens il faut bien légitime défense
l'argument des américains est
suffisamment forte si elle attend une
gold amer et moby lines prennent un
risque considérable est ce qu'à un
moment la survie de l'état d'israël a
été en jeu est ce qu'on prend ces
décisions n'ont pas mis en péril
l'existence d'états israël alors il ne
le semble pas qu'ils signent gère lui
même décrit un orfèvre en la matière a
dit assez clairement dans ses mémoires
beaucoup d'autres témoignages à aucun
moment semble-t-il l'état d'israël
n'était véritablement ont mis en péril
on a ajouté kissinger le fait que ça
n'aurait pas changé grand chose si cette
attaque israélienne avait eu lieu
arrêtons la politique fiction voyons
comment sur le terrain israël réagit à
la tacc arabe reprenant le cours de la
guerre
[Musique]
au début de l'offensive les arabes ce
triomphe équilibre des forces surtout
pour l'armement penche fortement de leur
côté
pour israël les premiers jours de guerre
sont terribles les télévisions du monde
entier diffusent des images de soldats
israéliens se rendant aux égyptiens la
revanche de 67
[Musique]
sur le golan les combats sont
effroyables
[Musique]
l'aviation israélienne dont le rôle
avait été déterminant pendant la guerre
de six jours connaît des pertes sévères
sous les coups des fusées sol air
un fantassin syrien sur trois est équipé
d'un lance missiles d'un type nouveau
qui fait des ravages des unités blindés
israéliennes entières sont mises hors de
combat
[Musique]
par disent qu'israël tente de colmater
les brèches sadate triomphe c'est lui
qui quelques semaines plus tôt à mise au
point avec le président assad cette
attaque surprise nom de code el badr
l'étincelle sa date vient de prouver que
l'armée égyptienne est capable de faire
reculer l'invincible de ça
golda meir la grand-mère d'israël accuse
le coup la voix brisée elle annonce au
pays des jours difficiles cette fois
explique-t-elle on voit bien qui est
l'agresseur
après 48 heures d'incertitude israël
commence à se ressaisir au sud salle un
atout de taille le sinaï et 200 km de
désert qui sépare les avant-postes
égyptiens des premières villes
israéliennes c'est là dans le sinaï que
se déroule la plus grande bataille
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale elle
tourne nettement à l'avantagé d'israël
[Musique]
la poussée égyptienne qui ne mettait pas
en péril la survie d'israël et contenus
c'est au nord sur le golan que se joue
le sort de la guerre c'est là que diane
va faire porter tout l'effort des
milliers de tonnes de matériel sont
acheminés sur le golan le centre de
damas et les raffineries de pétrole de
lattaquié sont bombardés par l'armée
israélienne qui a reconquis la maîtrise
du ciel
[Musique]
au sol on se bat pour chaque pouce de
terrain au corps à corps
[Musique]
le 16 octobre les commandos de tsahal
reprennent le mont nébo où flotte à
nouveau le drapeau frappé de l'étoile de
david symbole du renversement de
situation la contre offensive a été
foudroyante les blindés israéliens
continuent leur progression sur la route
de damas la deuxième phase de la guerre
à israël reprendre l'initiative
en posture difficile les syriens
demandent à leurs alliés de les soulager
le général fazli décide de faire passer
sur la rive est du canal une grande
partie de ses blindés et laisse dégarni
la zone située à l'ouest du canal dès le
12 octobre grâce aux satellites
américains les israéliens connaissent
cette faille dans le dispositif adverse
ils vont l'exploiter le général sharon
depuis longtemps avait préparé un plan
de contre-offensive en cas d'attaqué
égyptienne un plan audacieux presque
impossible qui consistait à lancer ses
troupes au nord du lac amer une région
jugée très difficile pour les blindés
personne n'y croit dans la nuit du 15 au
16 sans feu vert de ses supérieurs
sharon à la tête d'une division traverse
le lac amer sur des radeaux et surgit de
l'autre côté là où personne ne l'attend
entre la deuxième et la troisième armée
égyptienne
une division fonce vers le nord et la
seconde au sud direction suez ou théâtre
des opérations se déplacent c'est le
tournant de la guerre
le 20 octobre ça date constatant que les
forces de sharon sont en train de couper
en deux son dispositif se déclare prêt à
accepter un cessez-le-feu qui est votée
par l'onu le 22
mais les combats reprennent le lendemain
à cet instant la guerre du kippour entre
dans une nouvelle phase celle de
l'internationalisation du conflit
dès le 16 octobre les pays arabes
exportateurs de pétrole avait décidé
d'augmenter de 70 % le prix du brut pour
la première fois l'arme du pétrole est
utilisé inquiet de la déroute de leurs
alliés les soviétiques décide
d'organiser un vaste pont aérien afin de
ravitailler les armées arabes dans le
même temps il met en état d' alerte de
leur flotte de méditerranée et maëlys
trois divisions aéroportées mais il est
trop tard les hommes de sharon isole la
troisième armée égyptienne qui manque
d'eau de vivres de médicaments brejnev
le maître du kremlin donnent de la voix
il exige du président américain nixon
une action immédiate et conjointe ils
placent quatre nouvelles divisions sur
le pied de guerre nixon réplique en
mettant en état d' alerte les forces
nucléaires stratégiques
la guerre du désert va-t-elle provoquer
un conflit mondial
pierre milza restaurer semaine 3 octobre
vraiment il ya eu un risque de guerre
mondiale tout à fait personnellement je
pense tout à fait on a parlé après coup
d'une partie de complices d'un jeu de
conflits je ne le crois pas car il y
avait de part et d'autre au moment où
les deux grands reconnecte le
moyen-orient au système international
des risques et des enjeux majeurs pour
les soviétiques que le risque majeur
c'est l'ancien seulement de la troisième
armée c'est l'humiliation de sadate et
c'est par conséquent la perte totale de
leur prestige au moyen-orient' pour les
américains c'est l'intervention
soviétique ont bien orient avec eux ou
sans eux celui qui propose à bord
d'intervenir leur côté c'est la
réintroduction des soviétiques en egypte
donc d'un côté comme de l'autre ya un
seuil qui ne peut pas être franchies et
à partir de ce moment là il ya
effectivement un risque le risque c'est
que
sharon ou d
les israéliens en général passe outre
aux injonctions américaines en cercle
non seulement si elle aime l'armée la
troisième armée mais et obtienne sa
capitulation et humilie tellement ça
date que les soviétiques soit obligée
d'intervenir bien vrai risque alors pour
vous historien quand brejnev mais en
état d' alerte et division aéroportée
quand il met en état d' alerte la flotte
militaire années quand nixon en réplique
mais en alerte la force stratégie
nucléaire américaine ce n'est pas un
blog c'est vraiment une épreuve de force
s'est ni un blog ni une épreuve de
france ce sont des signaux ils ont l'un
et l'autre leur noyau dur d'intérêt ils
savent jusqu'où ils peuvent aller encore
faut-il le faire comprendre à
l'adversaire est le seul moyen de lui
faire comprendre c'est d' allumer des
clignotants messas a déjà été mis en
place quelques mois avant avec le traité
de washington sur la prévention de la
guerre nucléaire mis en place un certain
nombre de signaux là les soviétiques en
préparant leur parachutistes indique
clairement jusqu'où on peut pas aller et
le l'alerté nucléaire entre entre
guillemets le passage d'un degré un
autre passe de quatre à trois bien
encore de derrière c'est pas
véritablement une alerte et du caire
mais ça signifie quand même très
clairement aux soviétiques jusqu'où ils
peuvent aller c'est pas vraiment un
bluff c'est un signal on peut donc
révélé aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de
guerre mondiale regardons la suite des
événements le 24 octobre le conseil de
sécurité impose un nouveau cessez-le-feu
qui cette fois sera respectée pendant ce
temps sharon a consolidé sa position ces
soldats achève l'encerclement de la
troisième armée égyptienne et atteignent
le golfe de suez les chars israéliens
sont à 100 km du caire
[Musique]
le général sharon que l'on avait menacé
de la cour martiale reçoit en vainqueur
la visite de golda meir et de moshe
dayan la conquête de l'afrique a
commencé on filles en plaisantant le
baroudeur à son premier ministre
carte à l'appui sharon raconte sa
manoeuvre qui sera enseignée plus tard
dans les écoles de guerre
golda meir visiblement éprouvés répondre
aux interrogations des soldats pourquoi
at-on sacrifier les premières lignes en
laissant l'initiative aux as rome
[Musique]
sur le terrain en application du
cessez-le-feu un accord permet le
ravitaillement de la troisième armée un
convoi traverse les lignes
[Musique]
pour la première fois officier israélien
et arabes se retrouvent face à face
autour d'une table de négociations
le 11 novembre est signé l'accord dit du
km 101 golda meir obtient la libération
des prisonniers
pour israël la victoire un goût amer la
flamboyante équipe et de sharon n'efface
pas la panique des premiers jours israël
a douté le mythe de l'invincibilité date
1,2300 soldats israéliens sont morts
pendant cette guerre de trois semaines
on prix exorbitant pour un si petit pays
du côté arabe où le coût humain est
aussi très élevé
la guerre du kippour a rendu la
confiance et restaurer la fierté
vaincu mais non humilié sadate va
transformer une défaite militaire en
victoire politique
il s'engage dans un processus de
négociation qui conduira cinq ans plus
tard aux accords de camp david la paix
commence sa longue marche
thiam et zinc réaction de l'historien
devant ces images une certaine émotion
quand on vit des événements que nous
vivons en plus c'est cette guerre du
kippour pareil tout proche ont
l'impression que nous l'avons vécu il ya
peu de temps vingt ans ont passé et nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une toute autre
histoire autant d'histoires encore que
et le disais tout à l'heure il découle
est pas directement mais enfin il
découle de ce conflit j'aurai maintenant
on en vienne aux conséquences cette
guerre qui sont multiples qui sont
difficiles qui justifie qu'on puisse
parler à propos de la guerre du kippour
de rupture dans l'histoire du proche
orient d'abord ya des conséquences qui
sont économique puisqu'on a vu dans le
film que pour la première fois les pays
exportateurs de pétrole utilise comme on
la disait à l'époque larmes du pétrole
on va voir tout de suite et réactions
que ça provoque en occident comment
l'occident voit l'utilisation des termes
du pétrole comment il réagit
[Musique]
depuis longtemps on l'appeler l'or noir
et nous savions tous qu'il n'était pas
seulement le nerf de la guerre mais
aussi le sens du monde moderne il a
suffi d'une menace de disparition pour
que le pétrole deviennent vieux vinrent
la guerre du kippour les réductions de
production et l'embarras alors même des
pays réputés pour leurs amis qu'ils
arabes comme la france et l'angleterre
sûr que les temps difficiles était
revenu bien entendu c'est dans le
domaine de l'automobile que la
décélération s'est fait aussitôt sentir
le sang cesse de couler et
instantanément la paralysie frappe tout
l'organisme le tour de vis arabe a eu
sur le monde entier un effet dont ses
auteurs eux mêmes n'avaient pas mesuré
l'ampleur la dynamique europe
s'apercevait soudain avec affolement
qu'elle était en matière d'énergie aussi
pauvre que job on a vu surgir soudain
des oubliettes de la dernière guerre les
engins de remplacement les plus
farfelues
[Musique]
alors permis aux as que la crise du
pétrole provoquée par la guerre de
kippour a déclenché la crise économique
non alors le télescopage des images
évidemment nous invite à nous demander
s'il en est ainsi mais non elle a
accéléré contestable - elle accéléré la
crise mais la crise commence avant la
crise monétaire elle commence à se
profiler des 68 et les s'aggrave aux
états unis en 71 le renchérissement du
prix du baril de pétrole ne s'est pas 60
ça commence en 70 71 accord de téhéran
accord de tripoli simplement là les pays
exportateurs haram ont une occasion
formidable de dramatiser le débat est
d'obtenir en un seul coup toute la mise
ils le font donc ça accélère la crise
incontestablement mais ça ne déclenche
pas la crise autre conséquence la crise
en israël kolda mère est mise en
accusation sur son attitude au début de
la guerre est moche et d'aia lui-même
doit s'expliquer tout à fait d'ailleurs
on voit bien au chaud ces soldats c'est
très émouvant cette scène qui quelques
heures à quelques jours après le début
de la guerre aux proches et d'amis ou
deux mois pose des questions à à gold à
mai alors qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche
qu'est ce qu'on peut leur reprocher
certainement pas une erreur militaire
ils ont assumé un risque militaire
calculé pour remporter une partie
politique ils ont gagné finalement les
des américains ont livré ont organisé le
pont aérien ont livré les pièces de
rechange donc ils ont gagné c'est pas
tellement ça qu'on leur reproche même si
au premier degré c'est ça qu'on met en
avant on leur reproche une certaine
complet on leur reproche une certaine
imprévoyance car enfin ça fait deux ans
ou trois ans que sa date tous les ans
dit je vais reconquérir le sinaï nous
avons la possibilité de le faire et
c'est ça surtout que c'est sans
reprocher s'arrête un instant d'envoi
les manifestants là devant la knesset le
jour où diane doit venir s'expliquer
kolda maire prend sa défense est
lui-même moshe dyan ensuite répond à ses
détracteurs
le traumatisme en israël à la suite de
cette guerre provoque t-il une prise de
conscience est ce qu'on passe avec 1973
avec aguerris qui pour une sorte de
fatalité de la guerre à une nécessité de
la paix on va voir tout de suite les
grandes étapes qui conduisent de cette
guerre de kippour à la paix
d'aujourd'hui et on en parlera ensuite
[Musique]
quatre ans après la guerre du kippour
sadate est accueilli par match et diana
jérusalem et prononce le discours à la
knesset
deux ans plus tard le 26 mars 1979 c'est
la signature des accords de camp david
israël se retire de la totalité du sinaï
les angevins 82 salles entre au liban
c'est le début de l'opération paix en
galilée
sharon héros du kippour est mise en
accusation après le massacre des camps
de sabra et chatila il est limogé du
ministère de la défense
en décembre 83 sous la protection des
paras français arafat quitte le liban on
le croit politiquement fils mais
l'intifada le changement de la situation
internationale après la guerre du golfe
et la chute du mur de berlin permettent
des négociations qui ont abouti le 13
septembre dernier à l'accord olp israël
les israéliens sont reconnus et acceptés
les palestiniens ces émigrés de
l'histoire réintègre l'agglo à fond
[Applaudissements]
mon père me lisa les palestiniens
justement les grands oubliés de cette
guerre de kippour les grands absents
comment reviennent titre dans le jeu
comment on passe de cette logique de la
guerre à une logique de la paix d'abord
faut dire que là encore le ramasser
qu'elle nous et puis j'ai télévision de
prier sur pied il ya 20 ans il faudra
quand même 20 ans pour arriver à cette
étape actuelle qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas la dernière 3 y a deux conséquences
contradictoires le la guerre du kippour
amène ont quelques années le likoud au
pouvoir et durcit les positions d'israël
vis-à-vis des durs elle est durcie
vis-à-vis des durs pas vis-à-vis de ceux
qui acceptent l'état d'israël donc d'une
part c'est vrai que cette guerre elle va
renforcer les positions elle va amener
peut-être le réveil de ceux du syndrome
de l'holocauste après tout plus jamais
ça plus jamais se faire attaquer et se
retrouve dans cette situation mais en
revanche vis-à-vis de lutte lotissement
absolument son vis-à-vis de l'egypte qui
elles conformément au projet de sadate
qui était un projet demande aboutir à la
paix va proposer cette paix je crois que
ces images de deux ça date à la knesset
sont au moins aussi émouvante il faut
pas les oublier celles en plus il a payé
de sa vie que celle que nous avons vue
parce que c'est quand même quelque chose
qu'il sait comme la première étape et
ses quatre ans ce qui a changé aussi
fondamentalement dans le contexte
national pour ses 20 ans ces deux
événements majeurs évidemment évoqué
rapidement c'est la fin du bloc
communiste on a vu à quel point le rôle
de l'union soviétique dans la crise de
kippour et puis l'autre côté c'est la
guerre du golfe tout à fait je crois que
c'est fondamental est que le
l'éclatement de l'union soviétique et la
disparition d'acteurs soviétique est
fondamental dans la situation actuelle
enfin dans dans l'évolution des récentes
des événements on va dire quand même que
yasser arafat a fait les premiers pas et
les l'a fait parce qu'il est sans
véritables alliés extérieurs via la
situation totalement différente de celle
d'il ya vingt ans la disparition de
l'allié soviétique oblige quand même les
pays arabes et les palestiniens à
composer davantage sur le problème de la
reconnaissance d'israël
savoir le le regard de l'historien qu'à
l'habitude de la longue durée sur les
événements récents qu'on vient de vivre
sans cette reconnaissance mutuelle
sur la longue durée oui quand on ne
recule de l'historien sur la longue
durée l'historienne doit se taire en ce
moment parce que
le compte est donc et nous sommes nous
amène à essayer d un peu plus optimiste
possible malheureusement historiens
travaillent dans la longue durée dans la
longue durée et constate que
les difficiles qu un territoire qui
pouvant aux yeux d'une de toute une
partie de plus d'une partie du monde
apparaître comme un peu extérieur
survivent pensons aux états latins de
après la croisade mais l'histoire ne se
reproduit pas je crois qu'il faut avoir
il faut être historien faut avoir ce
regard de la longue durée faut dire
attention tout n'est pas joué ça sera
difficile nous faut en même temps être
un citoyen responsable dire que nous
devons d'être optimiste
merci pierre milza pour terminer
quelques livres qui nous ont aidés pour
cette émission jacques derogy jean-noël
gurgand israël la mort en face qui est
paru d'ailleurs il ya une vingtaine
d'années la guerre des six-jours la
victoire poids zones est et atlas
géopolitique du moyen orient et du monde
arabe avec une multitude de cartes qui
est mieux à comprendre l'évolution dans
cette partie du monde
chaque semaine après le dossier nous
vous proposerons une traversée du siècle
en images grâce aux archives pathé que
s'est il passé il y a vingt trente
quarante cinquante ans dans les derniers
jours du mois de septembre
23 43 53 et cetera voici notre rubrique
une semaine dans le siècle
hahaha
il y a vingt ans
le 26 septembre 1973
[Musique]
il y a trente ans en se ralliant à la
solution préconisée par le comité
d'experts franco-britannique la france
rouvre le dossier du tunnel sous la
manche le 25 septembre 1963 à la fin du
siècle dernier la sphère avait failli
aboutir mais l'angleterre tenait trop à
son splendide isolement dont blériot
sonna le glas en 1909 le groupement
d'étude a soigneusement examiné tous les
projets concevable celui du pont celui
du pont-tunnel celui d'une alim merger
poser à l'aide de plateformes ambulante
et enfin la solution d'un tunnel foré de
52 km dont 36 ou la mère qui reliera
sangatte et douvres ainsi de la cité à
la cité on peut espérer le feu vert sur
toute la ligne dès 1969
à marnes-la-coquette branle bas de
combat de l'amitié à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire du propriétaire de la villa
la look autrement dit maurice chevalier
le sourire rayonnant de maurice a montré
qu'il accueillit allègrement ses 75
berges conscient d'avoir exercé sa vie
durant un métier en or il ya 40 ans le
25 septembre 1958 roi du monde le
luxembourgeois rencontre l'équipe de
france maillot plus clair en présence du
phrase de luxembourg
attac france air de demi droit qu'en
revers ne fait une longue passe en avant
leur équipe bis en retrait un copain 10
ans et anthony ajoute difficilement son
tir et c'est le premier but pour la
france
en indochine le groupe de bombardement
gascogne multiplie ses attaques contre
les objectifs adverse est situé dans le
nord de la nappe
[Musique]
en moins d'une semaine une cinquantaine
de missions ont été effectuées visant à
la destruction d'entre-vous d'ateliers
et de voies de communication
il y à 50 les archives de septembre 43
ont disparu mais il y à 60 ans le 27
septembre 1933
huit mois après la prise du pouvoir par
hitler
non
pendant ce temps à paris cochez affronte
l'américain barnes
il y à 70 ans le 26 septembre 1923
concours aérien au bourget
un biplan bréguet capote à
l'atterrissage et prend ce
[Musique]
révélation ces jours ci sur la période
de l'occupation grâce au livre d'antoine
lefébure alors il fallait toutes les
vertus de l'administration française
pour pouvoir conserver dans des archives
c'est à deux milliers de petits secrets
qui est l émanation de la censure un
véritable service d'espionnage politique
antoine fait pur oui et pas seulement
espionnage politique c'est aussi le viol
de la vie privée organisée c'est à dire
que j'ai découvert dans aux archives
nationales et dans d'autres archives
quelque chose d'incroyable le
gouvernement de vichy dès la fin 1940 a
décidé d'ouvrir systématiquement tout le
courrier des français d'écouter les
conversations téléphoniques pour savoir
ce que les gens pensent et comment ils
vivaient ce nouveau régime et aussi
éventuellement pour trouver des complots
et ça a une hauteur incroyable 2
millions de lettres par mois ouverte et
toutes les conversations téléphoniques
écouter dès qu'une lettre ouverte était
estimée intéressante elle été recopié à
la machine à écrire en cinq exemplaires
envoyés à tous les ministères dont
aucune administration au monde n'a
jamais fait ça et donc on a des
témoignages historiques extraordinaire
pendant quatre ans la vie des français
la vie quotidienne leurs espoirs leurs
craintes leurs malheurs leur bonheur
alors si on prend le fil chronologique
on découvre qu'il y à une véritable
catastrophe morale je crois qu'on peut
s'exprimer ainsi au moment de la défaite
oui au moment de la défaite les
fonctionnaires de la censure il était
tout de même des milliers pour ouvrir
tous courriers se sont rendu compte de
l'ampleur de la deûle l'effondrement
psychologique morale les gens ne croient
plus à rien les gens sont désespérés ils
savent plus à quel saint se vouer et
sont totalement désinformées ce qui
explique pourquoi en majorité y pense
que seul pète un peu les sauver alors
ensuite on voit finalement
l'héroïsme qu'il fallait pouvoir rentrer
dans des réseaux organisés résistance
parce qu'au fond ballet français on
comprend mieux grâce à vos révélations
nicolas boni pétainiste ni résistants
parce que bah il fallait survivre il
fallait pouvoir manger la vie dans ce
livre c'est la vie c'est la vie
quotidienne la vie de tous les jours et
la première chose dans la vie tous les
jours c'est manger c'est se ravitailler
sait faire la queue pendant des heures
comme on l'a fait aujourd'hui en russie
au camp l'a fait en yougoslavie les
bombardements les communications
interrompues la france coupée en deux
voir couper en trois avec la partie
alsace et la partie nord les prisonniers
tous les membres de la famille qui sont
prisonniers les gens raflé pour le reste
on est et où en allemagne donc une
époque de mahler incroyable et dans ce
grand malheur faire un choix la
résistance la collaboration pétain et
cetera finalement ça n'a concerné qu'une
petite minorité la perception des
allemands alors ça au début on nous
raconte depuis une vingtaine d'années
qu'au début les allemands étaient
correctes et que finalement les français
les ont acceptées vous montrer grâce à
ces lettres qui n'ont jamais accepté les
allemands moi ça m'avait paru toujours
très bizarre cette espèce de légende
comme quoi les français avaient accepté
la collaboration l'arrivée des allemands
la conquête des allemands est en fait ce
qu'on découvre dans le courrier c'est
que dès le début ils étaient anti
allemands avant 1948 et en entier
allemand 1914 en 1870 antinazi anti
bosch et après la victoire nazie ils
sont toujours en qui bossent et des fins
40 on a des lettres on voit les gens
hurlaient protesté faire mauvaise
volonté on voit les envolées des
gendarmes même des policiers refusé
d'obéir aux ordres donnés par les
allemands et notamment la population
populaires ouvriers paysans etc révolté
par la présence des allemands est
persuadé que s'il y avait pénurie de
ravitaillement c'était la faute des
allemands qui prenait tout ce qui
n'était qu'en partie vrai retournement
de l'opinion publique en 43 finalement
milliers d' une france complètement
triste démunis
retournement oui on voit on voit dans le
courrier qu à partir de 1943 après la
victoire de stalingrad l'allemagne n'est
plus invincible et que beaucoup de gens
pensent que la victoire alliée possible
et on voit dans le courrier un
retournement est en même temps une
grande inquiétude car contrairement à ce
qu'on peut imaginer
les français ne savent pas ce qui va
arriver il ya de grandes craintes à
l'arrivée la libération du département
d'abord le débarquement ils attendent
toute l'année 43 ans voit dans le
courrier cette attente cette attente le
débarquement le débarquement la bbc et
même d'aider des éléments extrêmement
amusant parce que pour favoriser ce
bombardement on retrouve dans le
courrier des gens qui écrivent à la bbc
sans imaginer que le courrier va être
intercepté ce qui tournait montre une
certaine inconscience ils écrivent à la
bbc en disant voilà tel objectif
militaire évidemment c'est à côté de
chez moi mais prévenez la raf et
j'espère que vous aller viser juste
parce que ma maison et tout même à 300
mètres ça ce courrier existe dans les
archives et alors pour continuer ce set
cette collaboration avec la avec la
résistance ils interceptent eux mêmes ou
si le courrier c'est à dire qu'on voit
les postiers qui savent que le courrier
est intercepté par les allemands par
vichy intercepté le courrier qui est
destiné à la kommandantur les quelques
lettres de dénonciation qui existait
parce que contrairement à ce qu'ont
raconté ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qu'on voit bien dans le livre il y avait
très peu de il y avait très peu de gens
qui a envoyé des lettres de dénonciation
fallait tout de même avoir le lam bien
chevillée au corps excusez moi de
l'expression pour envoyer des lettres de
dénonciation et ses lettres de
dénonciation était détournée par des
postiers sympathisants de la résistance
qui savaient à quel point elle était
dangereuse ça aussi c'est quelque chose
qui n'avait pas été assez dit misérable
tas de petits secrets misérables petits
trafics tout était bon pour certains la
lâcheté comme l'héroïsme ont commencé à
surgir pendant cette sale période je
citerai qu'une seule une seule lettre
très rapidement c'est celle de
photomaton en mai 41 qui écrit aux
autorités allemandes même pas au à vichy
nous pensons que le rassemblement de
certaines catégories d'individus de race
juive dans des camps de concentration
aura pour conséquence administrative la
constitution d'un dossier d'une fiche
d'une carte spécialiste des questions
ayant trait à l'identité nous nous
permettons d'attirer tout
particulièrement votre attention sur
l'intérêt que présente nos machines
automatiques photomaton susceptibles de
photographier un millier de personnes
ainsi pour etc alors ça c'est
l'opportunisme c'est l'opportunisme
d'entreprise c'est vrai qu'on voit
énormément d'entreprises françaises de
chefs d'entreprises françaises pour
faire tourner l'appareil de production
pour faire tourner leurs sociétés qui
proposent directement aux allemands ou à
vichy de travailler et effective pendant
la guerre pendant l'occupation
le grand le grand preneur d'ordres
c'était la wehrmacht donc on
construisait les avions travers mart des
bateaux et on construisait des voitures
est effectivement même pour des tâches
de répression beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise n'hésitez pas d'autres
résistants patriotes refusé de faire ça
et vichy essayer de contrôler les chefs
d'entreprises français les empêcher de
travailler directement avec les
allemands pour organiser un échange
entre la france et les allemands et
l'allemagne mais les français toujours
habile à contourner la bureaucratie
essayé souvent directement travaillé
avec l'allemagne révélations aussi sur
la période de la libération alors là
aussi c'est incroyable vous nous la fait
vivre de manière quasi quotidienne à
lyon pendant l'été 44 et finalement
personne n'y croit cette libération les
gens n'y croient pas et les gens ne
savent pas ce qui va arriver c'est à
dire qu'ils sont extrêmement inquiets
ils ont l'impression que ça va peut-être
être la saint-barthélemy c'est dire
qu'il va y avoir des règlements de
comptes sauvage mieux d'ailleurs des
règlements de comptes mais moins moins
important que ce qu'ils pensaient il se
demande si c'est pas les russes
finalement qui vont les libérer et qui
vont passer d'une dictature est une
autre et les les troisièmes la troisième
tendance c'est de ne pas y croire c'est
à dire qu'ils ne sont pas sûrs que ça va
être vraiment la libération donc on sait
n'est pas la joie non c'est pas la joie
mais s'est drossée jamais la joie c'est
dire qu'il ya des choses dans ce livre
est dans ces lettres qui sont très très
drôle ya des gags extraordinaire on voit
comment un petit jeune homme de 18 ans
rentre dans la waffen ss parce qu'on lui
a dit qu'il aurait une moto et que
finalement avoir une moto allemande
c'est son plaisir il va rentrer dans la
section française de la waffen ss
essentiellement parce qu'il aime la moto
donc c'est des choses qu'on peut pas
imaginer mais en sélectionnant ses
lettres on rentre vraiment dans l'âme
profonde
c'est une espèce de psychologie des
profondeurs des ressorts cachés de
l'esprit humain désir d angoisse est
aussi évidemment de la cupidité et on
voit que la cupidité la méchanceté mais
aussi l'héroïsme et l'intelligence sont
sans limites et dans ce livre il ya un
passage comme ça entre tout est possible
rien n'est possible tout va arriver rien
va arriver un passage de choses
absolument ubuesque de choses horribles
et aussi de choses merveilleuses
magnifique et de et d'éléments carrément
comique même dans une période aussi
redoutable que la période de
l'occupation merci antoine eux fait bur
je rappelle le titre de votre livre les
conversations secrètes des français sous
l'occupation chez plon et puis je
voulais signaler deux livres l'un d'eux
david boal journaux intimes sous
l'occupation la méthode de boala était
de confronter la perception du vécu de
certains écrivains avec leurs journaux
intimes alors bien évidemment il parle
de marcel jouhandeau de drieu la
rochelle mais aussi évidemment de ernest
young r c'est un travail extrêmement
intéressant et puis un travail qui brûle
comme dit la préface il s'agit
d'innocence il s'agit de feu il s'agit
de vie cela s'intitule célébration dans
la tourmente et c'est l'énonciation de
tous les actes de résistance spirituelle
intellectuelle qui ont eu lieu dans les
ghettos ou à l'intérieur même des camps
de concentration et ça vient de sortir
aux éditions verdier mais tout de suite
recul notre rubrique pour mieux
comprendre l'actualité en la confrontant
à l'histoire
il suffit de voir leur chef de file
jeune manager sportif et poupin pour
comprendre que ce retour au pouvoir des
communistes polonais ce n'est pas le
retour du communisme ni du communisme de
staline ou de brejnev ni même celui du
général jaruzelski
n'est pas question d'arrêter les
réformes nous voulons seulement leur
donner un rythme plus humain nous sommes
partisans de l'économie de marché vous
ont adhéré le plus vite possible dans la
communauté européenne
la page est tournée et ses ex
communistes devenus sociaux-démocrates
ont défait les hommes de solidarité
parce que le pays ne supportait plus le
coût social des réformes les polonais
voulait souffler l'alternance à jouer
bien mais n'empêche n'empêche qu'il y a
dans tout cela une immense ironie de
l'histoire puisque ces polonais qui
plébiscitent d'anciens communistes sont
ceux là même qui de 1956 à 1989 ont
toujours été à l'avant-garde de la
bataille contre le système soviétique
et juin 1956 ce sont les polonais qui
avait avec les émeutes ouvrières de
poznan donné le signal du grand souffle
qui secoue cette année là l'europe
centrale ces pays satellisé parlure
c'est qu'on appelait par antiphrase
démocraties populaires en hongrie ce
vent d'espoir retombera dans l'horreur
d'une sanglante intervention de l'armée
rouge en pologne en revanche la pression
populaire fait rappeler au pouvoir un
dirigeant communiste condamné sous
staline vladislav gomulka qui rouvre le
dialogue avec l'église et permet
l'apparition de clubs et de journaux
catholiques indépendant ce n'était pas
grand chose mais un pluralisme
s'infiltre alors dans ses premières
fissures du totalitarisme et d'émeutes
en grande grève chin 1970 radom et aux
ressources 1976 dans ce qu'il y à 13 ans
la pologne devient le 31 août 1980 le
premier pays communistes à admettre le
pluralisme syndical
pour ce faire nos mairies des rebelles
et des raccords en puissance chez les
jeunes
[Musique]
forgée dans les grèves et fruit d'une
alliance enfin scellé entre l'opposition
intellectuelle et le monde ouvrier
solidarité va compter du jour au
lendemain 10 millions de membres
virtuellement toute la pologne est
active et créer de fait une vie
démocratique si puissante et
irréversible qu'elle laisse le bloc
soviétique désemparés
déjà empêtrés en afghanistan les
dirigeants russes n'osent pas intervenir
et c'est l'armée polonaise elle même
conduite par le général jaruzelski qui
déclare la guerre à son propre peuple
interdisant solidarité et instaurant
c'est l'expression officielle l'état de
guerre
on croit alors la normalisation
inéluctable mais la colonne y résistent
tient bon et quand la pérestroïka 1
révèle le total délabrement du bloc
soviétique lorsque mirail gorbatchev
signifie que chacun est libre de choisir
son destin ce sont de nouveau les
colonies qui sont les premiers à l'est à
se doter en 1989 d'un gouvernement non
communiste
les rvs à once à l'électricien de danse
sera bientôt président les résistants
d'hier deviennent ministres mais les
résistants les français le savent bien
sont rarement représentatif des
profondeurs d'une société ce sont des
hommes d'exception pour des périodes
d'exception trop grand trop carré pas
assez politique pour les temps de paix
comme toujours dans l'histoire on a
remercié les héros
si vous voulez rêver allez vous promener
dans la grande nef du musée des arts
décoratifs du palais du louvre les rênes
européenne et des parents du monde
entier ont prêté leur ouïe des oeufs
mais de1 période s'il vous plaît en or
en argent émaillé sertis de pierres
précieuses
si vous voulez voyager plongez vous dans
les mémoires du comte de forbin marin
bataille vers des mers il ne dédaignait
pas les méthodes des pirates pour mieux
servir le plus grand roi de l'univers
tangage répéter évasion garantie
un nouveau moment on dit le titre et en
plus c'est vrai du temps des cerises aux
cavaliers de l'apocalypse photo analyses
confidences tableau sa tente dans tous
les sens et surtout dans le bon sens
tant par le fond que par la forme
libération l'album pour ceux qui ont 20
ans aujourd'hui
notre jurassic park et germinal le
combat ne fait que commencer
les jeunes trancheront regardez sur la
fiche originale de germinal la gravité
de l'enfant zola et réédité par
petite nouvelle de l'histoire cette
vierge regard mélancolique vient d'être
découverte à la cathédrale de bourges
depuis trois semaines vous pouvez donc
voir une magnifique crucifixion située
en bord de mer
la guerre de troie n'a pas eu lieu nos
frères karmann viennent de le prouver
par ces fouilles archéologiques sur le
site de trouva en turquie mais
rassurez-vous l'iliade a bien pressés
dès le 10 et
les brûlures de l'histoire c'est presque
terminé au dossier de la semaine
prochaine les archives secrètes
soviétique vous savez qu'elles sont en
train de s'ouvrir et que cela constitue
une véritable mine pour les historiens
et bien vous y découvrirez entre autres
les relations entre paris et moscou
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et
puis la séquence actualité sera
consacrée à jésus oui jésus tout sur
jésus de sa date de naissance jusqu'à sa
résurrection les brûlures de l'histoire
bonsoir
[Musique]
et